[Music]
in a world where every holiday gets its
own horror movie st. Patrick's Day will
be exploited by a film that was stupidly
released in January that as far as
holiday themed serial killers go ranked
somewhere between Michael Myers and Jack
Frost no the other Jack Frost that's the
one leprechaun experience the perfect
Saint Patrick's Day movie in that you
have to be completely shit-faced to
enjoy it in this horror / comedy that
isn't scary or funny nice but managed to
stretch its premise into a leper thorn
of sequels taking its Tiny Terror from
Vegas to space and back to the hood
again journey to a place they'll try to
convince you is in Southern California
assuring everly health and join a
handful of walking horror movie cliches
with Rachel from friends as the spoiled
brat there's no swimming pool there's no
shopping mall there's no cable a Joey
Lawrence reject as the Joey Lawrence
type and two characters who feel like
they wandered in from a completely
different movie about a kid saving money
for his simple friends bring operation
his breathe he doesn't watch as they
team up to defeat evil the only way they
know how
spending 90 minutes beating the [ __ ] out
of respected English actor Warwick Davis
[Music]
hey leave willow alone so gear up for
the movie that seems intentionally
created for a st. Patrick's Day drinking
game and take a shot every time the
Leprechaun says who he is
[Music]
says what he wants someone doesn't
believe it's a leprechaun
Pyrus culture gets set back decades a we
personal Efron a condom native so me
wearing gorgeous or little people's
rides get set back centuries we people
have their magical way lucky charms
oh man we are so gonna get wasted
starring Georgia fer Aniston and
hillbilly Hercules I know you are but
what am I
Dennis the sociopath Irishman Irishman
and Tyrion Oh Lannister The Hobbit
battle of the lucky charm ease I smell
reboot be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers a screen junkies still
one more of the leprechaun then join us
today at 4:30 p.m. Pacific time for a
st. Patrick's Day watch party of
leprechaun for leprechaun in space
featuring your favorite screen junkies
personalities we'll be broadcasting live
on YouTube and you can watch leprechaun
4 with us via movies on Bray just go to
our YouTube page or click below to join
the fun ooh that's a bingo
whoo manners maketh man come in and try
not to murder any of my guests I like
chocolate milk